and finally new rules since so much of
what passes for today's journalism is
anything but how about some rules for
identifying actual news for example when
an internet headline reads you won't
believe yes you will and no it's not
news when anyone is demanding an apology
unless they have hostages that's not
news and when the offended group are
identified as the Internet Twitter or
people it's nobody I guarantee when you
click on the story you find out the
Internet is three losers with the
combined Twitter following of their mom
[Applause]
I used to think something was news if a
journalist reported it but really I live
in a world where it's news if mariah
carey's tip flops out because twitter
will respond and then a journalist
reports on the controversy if a boob
flops in the forest and no one is around
to hear it it doesn't make a sound but
if three jackasses tweet about it it's
news here's an example from this week
this is a picture from the premier of
red sparrow which looks pretty good by
the way Jennifer Lawrence plays a
beautiful woman who uses sex as a weapon
on orders from Moscow it's working title
was i Ivanka anyway here's the headline
from Elle online at a hundred other
sites Jennifer Lawrence's latest red
Sparrow photo call has twitter calling
out gender inequality yes CeCe cuz the
men are wearing coats but she's not and
even though that was her choice
someone with 11 followers didn't like it
so the story was reported in the New
York Times The Washington Post New York
Post Fox News BBC Vanity Fair Chicago
Tribune the Guardian the National Review
now all these esteemed news
organizations aren't saying they think
it's a big deal because they're serious
journalists they'd rather be writing
about Syria and the oceans dying
but oh the humanity Jennifer Lawrence
didn't have a code wrap her up wrap her
up
[Applause]
you know look this is not an outlier
this is a constant and prominent part of
today's journalism creating some
[ __ ] non-issue that a few trolls
will predictably go apeshit over and
then reporting on those unrepresentative
tweets like all of America's talking
about nothing else
Justin Timberlake used a projection of
prints for his Super Bowl halftime show
and people are furious no nobody cared
people are really mad that Shaun White
dragged the American flag after he won
the gold no not even a little you
[ __ ] liars Weight Watchers is
targeting teams and Twitter is outraged
no one isn't it's the same three people
and it's not hard to find three people
who are mad at anything I could say good
morning on Twitter and three people
would object good in your privileged
world Bill Maher
no wonder fake news resonates so much
with Trump fans because so much of it is
fake
just nonsense made to keep you
perpetually offended with an endless
stream of controversies that aren't
controversial and outrageous that aren't
outrageous because places like The
Huffington Post and BuzzFeed and salon
they make their money by how many clicks
they get yes the people who see
themselves as morally superior are
actually ignoring their sacred job of
informing citizens of what's important
and instead sowing division for their
own selfish ends hey wait isn't that
what Russia was doing to us yeah it is
and we have to stop both of them from
using us as the [ __ ] in their [ __ ]
fights and so I conclude by saying to
all those who were barely able to go on
after seeing kendall Jenner tweet the
wrong color emoji a bit of advice if you
don't like what Kendall did with a brown
fist and her tweet do not watch her
sister's sex tape